what makes a player iconic enough to
become the face of their game unreal and
that All-Star team he did he goes in for
everything more teasing
I'm out of here baby oh my God the
definition of ancient Steel in most
cases It's a combination of skill
C and accolades
let him know that is a huge performance
from Crimson but no King rules alone for
every extraordinarily talented
competitor out there there is someone
who captures the fans Hearts through
other means
[Music]
and while most of us probably think of
bolo when we hear Rainbow Six Siege
there is another player an oddity simply
known as jinxy writing himself into the
history books in a very different sort
of way where are you going
where are you going you're lost Dollar
Tree headset
it's usually
[Music]
so how did being a console player help
jinxy get so popular will he ever
attempt to go pro and is this guy really
the future of C
you're wander in your possession
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so before we get started I just
want to remind you all we got merch you
can have a look at all the cool stuff
we've got in our Esports collection over
at
shop.thescore.com and pick up something
nice for yourself or your friends
alright so if you are an OG Rainbow Six
Siege fan jinxy's existence might feel
like a slap in the face to everything
you think you know about the game unlike
basically every other big Siege content
creator jinxy plays using a controller
instead of a mouse and keyboard but more
importantly that's because he plays on
Console
yo we're not going to talk about the aim
but we're not going to talk about the
aim but
he's got every variable in his favor
right now he is like the like poster
child of Siege console we don't have
many of those he actually like
legitimately uses a controller it is
very good so people are like okay this
guy like actually is a controller he
plays console he's actually really good
kicking everyone's ass that's on mouse
and keyboard so like that's that makes
that's a huge thing too but despite
being
goaded on the sticks
he seems to have zero interest in going
pro probably because unlike on stream
you can't really let it all hang out on
land let me see this
and the platform where he's making the
biggest impact isn't twitch or YouTube
It's the Zoomer Wonderland Tick Tock
wait a minute boom shakalaka 4v3 now my
energy switches I know everybody's
focusing on me gotta get that camera off
of me they all know where I am but it
doesn't matter Ben that's the t-hunting
I hear one on the ladder
make it a little bit too much useless
[Music]
okay so why is any of this important for
as long as it's been an option a debate
has raged on about the merits of mouse
and keyboard over controllers to play
Shooters and Siege is no different now a
mouse and keyboard setup is
traditionally considered Superior
because it allows for better aim and
movement and this is what you see most
pros and content creators using that
arcade
that one
another one but when it comes to the
Casual player base the majority of them
I play on consoles and since using a
mouse and keyboard with your Xbox or
Playstation is in fact tantamount to
cheating most people play on controllers
I don't remember when I read this and
I'm pretty sure it still stays true but
like the PlayStation and Xbox Community
for Siege is far superior than PC and of
course it's like you know the console
guys are going to want to watch PC it's
like you know it sees the high skill
ceiling it's like everybody drives a car
but it's like they're gonna watch F1
because they you know go fast it's more
more room for air and it's more
entertaining but as entertaining as it
may be attempting to end emulate someone
who's not even using the same tools as
you is sort of like trying to teach
someone how to play basketball using a
tennis ball all good and fine if you're
already insane just probably not your
ticket into the NBA if you're just
starting out I just want to play
football and go home console Siege is
legitimately way more popular than PC
Siege but because the pro scene lives on
PC console players never really got
represented in content Creation in fact
the first ever Siege Invitational was
played on both PC and console then the
scene got progressively more hardcore
and moved towards PC leaving the massive
console player base in the Lurch and
this is where jinxy swooped in to save
the day not only does he use a
controller like the majority of his
audience he's actually really good at it
even better than the mouse and keyboard
cheaters infecting his console lobbies
the one who knocks
clever 10 seconds left
yeah
naturally anyone watching jinxy would
begin to wonder if we might have a
second controller wielding coming of
bolo on our hands in reality though
rather than jinxy infiltrating Esports
it's actually the other way around
successful full-time content creators
like jinxy have helped lure the game's
biggest star into an early retirement
instead juanathai the scene isn't in
that good of a spot and now I'm kind of
out like a Crossroads it's like do I
want to keep sacrificing my brand my
community That Built Me Up and got me to
this insane level that I'm at right now
or do I keep kind of I guess staying
with the sinking ship and if we're
talking about a community this my
friends is how we end up on Tick Tock
the platform has unsurprisingly taken
over as the go-to for those looking to
reach a generation of viewers who want
their content served out in easily
digestible bite-sized portions which
happens to be something that jinxy has
gotten down to a science I mean
obviously it's been cracked out on
tiktok completely which I think was an
Avenue that a lot of us other
contigrators just kind of slept on but I
also think he really appealed us to this
like Zoomer culture this is how an R6
Champion prepares supper
[Music]
I'm gonna be competing in the 2026 World
Cup United States of America you just
got your new starting Striker
10 A.M
bring out of bed
City good morning it's time for your
walk
oh don't Johnson on the yard but where
did jinxy even come from well just a few
short years ago he was just your average
Siege fan lurking in twitch chat but
eventually jinxy saw something beyond
the established status quo an
opportunity to connect with Siege
players on their level by getting sweaty
using the ultimate casual Hardware all
while never taking himself too seriously
wait what the just happened man
jinxy's hyper casual zero filter no
shits given about the pro scene approach
Drew fans in by the thousands he just
has like a really good funny energy
about him and it's like he keeps it up
for the whole stream too like he doesn't
really have like down time like other
people it's like they start off the
stream strong and they're like screaming
and doing really he like keeps that up
for like 12 hours I don't know how he
does it but good for him like and since
social media is just one big pond the
waves he made over on Tick Tock sent
ripples through more traditional content
creation platforms as well
oh yeah
oh I know that is Hubba Bubba
bubblegum Pig
he lagged he laughed
now I know there's always talk about
Siege dying and all that but what we may
be looking at actually isn't to death at
all but rather a rebirth and since jinxy
is literally the most popular Siege
content creator out there at the moment
well everyone I present to you the new
face of Rainbow Six Siege
all right all right Jokes Aside jinxy is
actually an immensely important figure
in the siege scene right now in no small
part because he actively chooses to
continue playing Siege his way each and
every day and his contributions are not
lost on the rest of the siege community
so jinxi has like the most of course
right now like most popular twitch
stream for Siege and he is for a console
in the most popular demographic and you
know he does very well at it and he
stuck to it a lot of the previous
console streamers would you know oh I'm
Wayne you know PC goal 1200 or whatever
and the rise they got to that marker all
right back to PC because they just want
to hop in the trend right like they see
the successful PC players but they don't
realize the untapped potential that
there is console so really good playing
field for GNC and he's stuck to it when
nobody else wanted to and he he's
reaping the rewards it's just good to
see like someone with that personality
kind of just like being successful
because like I used to have kind of like
the type of person nachos like full
extent but like to that personality so
it's just good to see people like that
thriving just being themselves and being
comfortable being outside of himself in
that front of that log audience so it's
just like it's really good to see it I'm
really happy for him we all benefit from
this hey we're not competing with each
other we're in uh co-workers right like
and if he makes Siege do well it helps
us do well as well he specifically has
drawn a lot of new viewers to the
category and it's actually kind of funny
he used to watch my streams a really
long time ago and he had like 20 viewers
and he would host me and watch my
streams he was always a super nice like
kid even back then I'm happy to see him
doing well and hey it's helping Siege is
a category too and couldn't ask for a
tap into a nicer person so we can all
agree that jinxy is living breathing
proof that walking the path less taken
can lead you to the very top of the
mountain that it's possible to represent
a game you love in your own unique way
and still blow everyone else out of the
water that sometimes the future lies a
little Beyond fund the pale and that's
perfectly okay do you honestly think you
could defeat me in a 1v1 in Tom Clancy's
Rainbow Six seat well tonight is your
chance we're going live
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
foreign